in use that really shouldn't surprise
anybody Pokemon go devotees are finally
dissipating and deciding to play other
games the mobile game has already lost
more than 15 million daily users since
this time last month according to axiom
Capital Management who published some
ominous graphs after peaking at around
45 million worldwide daily active users
are now down to 30 million which is
still a hell of a lot of people catching
pokemon mobile research company app
topia piled on adding the pokemon go
engagements has decreased by more than
fifty percent and after a massive spike
in searches for augmented reality the
phrase has been googled far less since
the initial launch of pokemon go that
said it is still more popularly search
now than before Pokemon go into our
lives senior analyst Victor Anthony
added that the downturn of Pokemon go
has reassured investors who are on edge
about users spending less time on
Facebook Twitter and snapchat in favor
of catching the pokemons Pokemon go
still holds the number one [ __ ] for top
grossing app on the iOS App Store
meaning it's still making a ton of money
oh it has dropped to number 11 from its
prior position as the number one free
app let me know how you think we'll see
Pokemon go evolve from here and if
you're still playing it and stay tuned
to gamespot for all the latest